this was controlling I've been answering
your question you answer mine it's
actually not my job to answer your
questions I've asked you two questions
should a m St in power and are they a
terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV is the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on PEB on sensor gen Z
workers take an average of one day off
sick every week due to mental health
costing Britain 150 billion pound a year
are we all really losing our minds or
maybe our backbones will debate plus
Trump returns to uncensored that's his
daughter-in-law a senior campaign
advisor Lara Trump who joins me live to
discuss another barnstorming victory for
the former president and some pan
station seals officer Elton John's
legendary public piano after a YouTube p
this was ordered to stop playing by
tourists claims of Chinese Communists Dr
K joins me
live live from the news building in
London this is Pierce Morgan un
good evening from London welcome to Pi
Morgan un sens at no point in human
history have we been more self-aware
about mental health and if stress is a
pandemic there's a multi-billion dollar
market for the vaccines you might start
your day by swallowing a Prozac before
unpacking your trauma with a therapist
popping a daer pan for your workplace
anxiety and winding down with meditation
or Wellness app and a desperate hope of
getting some sleep if you've got it
there's a product for it we've never be
more medicated more therapized or more
legitimized for confronting our feelings
and many would say quite right too but
every study is now telling us that we've
also never apparently been more
depressed or riddled with anxiety
something is broken here and the answer
can't be that it's all in our minds a
new study published today said that gen
Z employees in Britain miss an average
of one work day every single week due to
mental health costing the nation a
rather stressful $138 billion dollar uh
pounds a year and to be clear from the
outset mental illness is a deadly
serious thing like every serious illness
it needs serious treatment I would never
question people who are clinically
depressed or genuinely suicidal but I do
think it's time to draw a line between
mental illness and mental health Matt
Walsh who's been on the show many times
the stood in a motive debate about this
in recent days when he tweeted that
depression is one of the basic side
effects of being conscious he later said
that labeling negative emotions and
behaviors as diseases is exactly the
problem precisely what the psychiatric
field has done maybe has a point the
global therapy industry is worth $150
billion and it's growing at a rate of
knots young people in particular are
relentlessly bombarded by content which
gives them every reason to feel
uncomfortable and anxious and the act of
encourag to then vaunt their suffering
is that part of the problem and Britain
used to celebrate the so-called stiff
upper lip I guess that boils down to
being resilient in the face of adversity
if times are tough but we were told to
Soldier on keep pounding find a way
through it's become more fashionable and
again many people think this is the
right way to go to be perhaps more in
touch with your trauma to get help for
it to talk about it publicly criticism
though has now become recategorized as
shaming disagreement becomes very
quickly described as hate all
confrontation is categorized as violence
is that right it should be no surprise
that there's been a bit of a cultural
fightback huge influential characters
like Andrew Tate for good or bad I've
encourage their millions of followers to
see depression as a man-made concept
which ironically is unbefitting of
men what do you believe about depression
do you believe depression is a real
thing I can't become clinically
depressed why do you know because I
don't believe in it I can't be haunted
by a ghost if I don't believe in ghosts
well that's saying I'm never going to
die because I don't believe in it it's
ridiculous well he's completely wrong as
I said there and there is a middle
ground though and I'm glad call out the
excesses on both sides of the argument
just as when I question Tate's creative
interpretation of the tears he shed in
jail did you shed tears in your cell
there were tears that ran down my face
but I did not cry I mean that's crying I
would disagree yeah you were crying
Andrew tape maybe you're a little bit
depressed as you sat in your prison C
nothing wrong with that just confront
your feelings but somewhere in his
bombast Tap maybe has a point podcaster
zubie struck a call with me this week
having just returned to the UK from New
York when he posted if you absolutely
believe you will get jet lag and that's
inevitable you will get jet lag I don't
get jet lag well as someone who just
flew back from New York and has jet lag
maybe I should think harder about not
having jet lag you might be right we do
talk ourselves into a lot of this stuff
and we maybe have lost sight of the idea
that everyday stresses and strains are
as much about our ability and will to
manage them as they are about whatever
is getting us down maybe we've forgotten
how to keep calm and carry on maybe we
should stop thinking that's a bad thing
to be frowned upon a lot of people
making a lot of money by telling us
we're not okay what Jo me to discuss
this is my pack talk to he contributor
Esther Kracker associate Daily Mirror
Kevin McGuire legal journalist Ava
Santina and we're joined from across the
pond by the podcast H I mentioned
earlier zubie uh zubie let me start with
you um because I liked your comment
about jet lag it hasn't worked work for
me but I like the inspiration that you
gave me to try and make it work and I'm
working on my I don't have jet lag
skills um on The Wider point it's a mind
field this whole area of mental health
there's no doubt to me uh I've got three
sons in their 20s and I know lots of
their friendship groups there are a lots
of young people suffering from genuine
anxiety I wouldn't categorize it as
clinical depression um it may be in some
cases but just general levels of anxiety
that I don't think think existed when I
was that age a lot of it may be uh phone
driven you know being subjected to
endless terrible imagery which we never
used to have to be exposed to When We
Were Young I'm not sure what it is but
when you look at this whole situation
what do you
think yeah Piers I think it's one of
those situations where multiple things
are true at once and people often go to
extremes when it's not necessary it can
absolutely be true that there are people
who suffer genuine serious traumas which
require things like Ser therapy and that
there are people who have real mental
illnesses or severe mental health issues
where medication temporarily or even on
a perhaps longer term may help and that
can be true it can also be true that
many things are being overdiagnosed and
that The Human Condition itself has been
pathologized in various ways and that
there are all sorts of influences out
there which are not necessarily serving
people's best interests because they do
make money billions of dollars and
pounds off of certain medications you
said the therapy business itself is
worth I think you said
$150 billion dollar um per year and so
there are very misaligned incentives
here but I do think that one thing that
happens with a lot of these
conversations is people are very willing
to talk about the symptoms but as a
society we don't often go deep on what
some of the causes are we'll talk about
Mental Health we'll talk about
depression and anxiety but there won't
be a lot of talk about the family
situation and the households that people
are growing up in their friend uh social
networks not not online social networks
but their real social network are they
part of a church are they part of strong
communities what are their beliefs what
are their what's their physical health
status physical and spiritual health are
connected to mental health so similar
with many other issues we talk about
everything at the symptom level and try
to find a pill or a potion or a therapy
that is going to work for everybody but
I think in many cases we're not really
getting to what the root of the issue is
you touched on one other thing which is
the rise of use of smartphones and
social media that's absolutely having an
impact on people's mental well-being
being bombarded by all these images and
opinions and just pure amount of
information every day this is something
very new that our ancestors didn't have
to deal with so I'm not surprised that
there are more young more and more young
people every year who are reporting that
they're having anxiety depression or
whatever else it may be yeah AA it is a
Minefield just to even talk about this
you know I could almost feel us all you
know you're treading on eggshells with
this not to say the wrong thing not to
be insensitive but also to recognize
this survey that's come out it's pretty
shocking that you know genz kids are
missing a day a week at work and the on
cost of all that what do you think is
going on here well I agree with the
premise there of your guess Ubie because
you need to be talking about like what
are the causes of this if you look at
gen Z at the moment some of most of genz
are spending up to 0% of their pay
packet on rent they're poor and they're
not having a nice time at home and I
think that really drives into anxiety
and also as you talked about their phone
dependency but yeah I mean look there is
a conversation we need to be having
about self diagnosis that is going on
particular on Tik Tok argument I do
understand we're not in the best of
economic circumstances but you know like
I said there's less poverty now in this
country than there's ever been exactly
and I grew up I grew up Rel you but the
thing is I I GRE up population that we
would categorize as poor Rel IW up G and
I I've seen triple the amount of
depressed people in this country than
there so I don't think necessarily
material dep I also well of people who
are extremely depressed ex I'm very
riddled with anxiet I'm not sure that
money or whether you're poor or Rich I'm
don't sure that's really what the core
here I actually think the dopamine
impact of of phones bringing so much
stuff into their heads all day in a way
we never ever had to experience When We
Were Young when I was young you just you
didn't have any phones there was no
internet now if there a War somewhere
they're seeing you know kids heads being
blown off in real time all day long to
have a bad effect but there was also
suffering in silence after the first and
second world war people came back they
were absolutely traumatized and it
wasn't recognized and their lies were
blighted uh as a result now I love zub's
positive view of overcoming jet lag but
it exists mental illness exists but you
have a scale where the will be people
clinically depressed and you'll have
just have other people who feel down for
whatever reason they completely
different category and if we're
medicating them is there a danger that
you talk too much about these things you
encourage people as with everything in
life yeah if there's too much
conversation yeah right and it's pretty
well been wall toall 247 now for a few
years I see no evidence necessarily that
it's working in reducing the number of
people saying they're feeling bad that's
right it's the reverse of not talking
about it and denying it and then people
hurt uh you know real pain problem can
talk you can talk yourself into it
there's no question we've medicalized
real life that's the problem someone who
has lost a spouse for instance of course
will feel sad and depressed but to say
that they have depression and has to
take a pill that's a problem because
you're not treating it the way that it
should be treated real life happens sad
things happen and we have to have a way
to deal with it young people also lack
purpose right if they're seeing all
these you know people getting rich and
having Bugattis online they're thinking
how am I supposed to have that what is
my purpose in life Fe missing out the
Envy factor I mean bringing back in here
um you know I think all these things
come into play the difference like I
said between when I was young and young
people now is their ability to have all
this staring at them all day long you
know when I was young the most exciting
thing you had in front of you was a
conquer fight you know and you'd be
studying conquers outside in fresh air
we didn't have any phones there was no
internet there was nothing like that um
you you weren't really aware of all the
bad stuff going on unless you watched
the one TV News Bulletin now kids not
only aware of it they're seeing it in
real
time yeah there are a lot of different
factors I mean social media and
smartphones absolutely play some role in
here I'd say another thing that has
massively changed over the decades as
well is just the situations that people
are growing up in their environment how
many different communities that they're
plugged into and how strong are those
communities we we know that there's an
epidemic of loneliness that we talk
about we talk about the epidemic of uh
suicide particularly male SU suicide
we're talking about all of this mental
health things and it's like all of the
things that help to keep individuals and
societies sane and stable from family to
Faith to community to um you know the
the sense of meaning and purpose that uh
someone else brought up earlier all of
these things have also been eroded over
the past let's say 50 or 60 years so
when it comes to these situations I mean
why are people so Desperately Seeking
therapists I think in many cases sure
there might be people who really
genuinely need a professional therapist
but I think there are also people who
just need someone to talk to and they
don't really feel like they have friends
or they have parents or family members
that they can confide in and talk about
these day-to-day issues and then it
builds up and it gets to a stage where
they feel like the only thing that they
can do is go to a therapist or take
medication or perhaps even do something
that's far more drastic I mean in the
United States for example I read
recently that 80% of the world's
painkillers are sold in the United
States
80% I mean we think we're overmedicated
here my God I mean in in in the US it's
it's really out of
control yeah it's crazy I mean the USA
has I believe 4% of the world's
population and then as you said they're
taking 80% plus of the pain medication
and things like o opioids and the these
things are causing massive crises in the
USA every year over 100,000 people in
the USA American citizens are dying of
drug overdoses that's 100,000 deaths so
imagine how many other people are
abusing those substances and these are
genuinely scary numbers a 100,000 people
dying per year of something that is
completely avoidable um I think that
should be much bigger news but as I said
I I don't know every single solution um
but I think for the diagnosis we have to
go down the tree a little bit and not
just hack at the branches and the Twigs
but we need to get to the root of the
problem and it's not going to be one
single thing it's going to be me
multiple things and I think several of
them have been mentioned yep I
completely agree let's take a short
break and a keep our Stella pack uh
we're gonna come back and we have day
two of Barby gate the shocking snob
apparently to Margo Robbie in the best
actress category at the Oscars and Greta
goig and Best Director but good old Ken
he had the last laugh didn't he well
Ryan goling of course he plays Ken in
the movie he's absolutely guilin uh
horrified shocked issued a statement
about how outraged he is his two female
colleagues didn't get nominated ated
hasn't yet offered to hand back his
nomination and has given no indication
he won't be leaping along to the Oscars
to receive his award if he should get
one so we'll debate that after the
break we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online and we're on your smart speaking
criminals to useing XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn do you know what I
love about SP today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any your will because
he delivered the referendum that he said
he would deliver the Tories love a scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella bravman she's
heading up one side and richy soon at
the
other Zak stama is about to help make
children even taller
now go that's what's going to happen if
you vote
labor Long Live JK Rowling and her right
to stand up for women we can only pity
those who despise their straightforward
Politics as somehow
dangerous the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil Kevin O
Sullivan is the worst presenter on talk
TV sitting on his
fat like brought to you by Steve KH the
mayor of London bought us with our own
money the the mayor fireworks very
rarely meet anybody that says you know
the thing about London is it's got a
great mayor it's a deep charm brilliant
Guy this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film stop creating
all of these funny little factions with
their funny little names the new
conservatives the ERG the common sense
research group the red wool red trouser
popcorn I mean popcorn what what is that
I just cannot see if richy suak goes
does what David Frost what Lord fros
wants him to do and go further to the
right on taxes and immigration that that
would turn around the what's predicted
by this poll in a landslide Donald Trump
didn't just win he obliterated this is a
guy facing nearly 100 criminal charges
and yet all that's done is actually make
him more popular Trump is canny enough
to know that all publicity is good
publicity I don't want a president who's
been impeached if he's able to bamboozle
you that's the way it goes did my 6
months I came back nobody would touch me
I put my head down and persisted and
carried on when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel El this was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question I've
asked you two questions should a mass
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV
it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that lman said you were the funniest of
them all he also said you were very
insecure L was on the cover of Success
magazine you know Dave I'm on a magazine
called super Success
magazine my number one bucket list has
been to get inside it's not like it
invite you says a lot about Taylor Swift
what what do you make of the fact she's
now this billionaire I think it's
wonderful I breaking all record beating
Elvis Michael Jackson all yeah I think
it's wonderful I think it's great Joe
Biden he's fine to be president I'm a
fan I like the man I've known him for
years uh no I like him I think he's a
good guy and you know the economy is
doing pretty good I don't want a
president who's been impeached if he's
able to bamboozle you if you choose to
have someone who's a criminal as
president I have to accept your choice
the way it goes so that Elon Musk is a
genius yes genius very bright guy I got
a face full of gas and you were
literally on fire when rich people catch
on fire the public loves
[Music]
it
well that was a trailer for a brilliant
interview with Jay Len the king of late
night in America for so many years great
battle with the great David lean but he
also has the most incredible car
collection of any human being I've ever
seen in my life 260 I think plus
supercars one of which alone's worth 20
million and he takes a guided tour of
his amazing cars and gives me a quite
remarkably open and honest interview
it's like Mr America jeno so well worth
watching that'll be tomorrow night a
special on PE Morgan unsensed jeno
anyway my pack is still with me um me
start with you over about Barbie we
discussed this briefly yesterday but
it's it's been ratcheted up by Ryan
Gosling's rage filled statement about
himself being nominated for an award at
the Oscars but not the two women who
were basically behind the movie success
Margo Robbie and CR gby here's my
question why the hell should they have
been nominated I thought the movie was
awful I thought it was man hating
patronizing
anti-patriarchy nonsense from start to
finish I didn't think margar Robbie who
I love and think he's a brilliant
actress was very good in this I thought
he was probably the best of a bad bunch
of acting performances and gr go all
right she's a good director but really
one of the best directed movies of do me
a favor there's a woman who has been
nominated in the best director category
who made a fantastic film right that's
on Merit why should just could you make
a silly movie attacking men using real
life dolls why should you get any
nomination look I I I have to say I was
kind of I was slightly confused why
people were so upset and calling it
misogynistic because the other people
who were nominated were women so I
wasn't quite understanding that I also
didn't understand the comparisons with
Hillary Clinton so a lot of people were
saying that because you know this is why
we she's compared herself to it she has
this is why we haven't had eight years
of Hillary Clinton because people don't
choose women and I don't agree with that
at all however what I would say is more
women got nominated this year apparently
than ever before what I would say is
perhaps there is a little bit of a
spirit in the air which is you know a
little taste of you do people just not
really like what girls like you know you
know a lot of women really enjoyed that
movie a lot of men enjoyed that
movie and you know I guess the Ultimate
Prize is the billion dollars that it
made at the box office but look it was
the most popular you know also made a
billion dollars at the box office all
three Jurassic worlds and one of the
Star World the Transformers yeah exactly
let me bring in zubie zubie where do you
sit on Barbie gate and this furor is
erupted because Margo Robbie and gr gwin
have been snubbed I don't think they
should have ever been even
considered I'm going to be as honest as
I always am and I really don't
care does it okay let me try and make
you care do you think that the reaction
to this snub is ludicrous or not yeah I
yeah I I I think it's silly um I think
we certainly have much bigger fish to
fry as a society from the precursory
glance I've taken at articles it does
look like the movie did get eight Oscar
nominations it just seems that people
are mad that uh the director and Margo
Robbie specifically didn't get
nominations but it looks like other
people from the film did including
another one of the female actresses so
um yeah I I think that the criticisms
are silly but also expected Kevin where
do you sit on this well we were told
there's no Ken without Barbie but there
clearly will be the Oscars that's why I
love it that's why I love that Ken's
getting the last laugh they make him out
to be a total numb skull in the movie
he's the downtrodden oppressed guy who
ends up getting dumped she doesn't need
a man she can do it all herself and you
know what turns out Ken has the last
laugh it's the middle of the film when
he takes over of course you know she has
two two3 of the film he's got the middle
middle third but I can see from his
point of view it's a little bit
embarrassing because the film's not
called dominated for something that you
three were involved in I wouldn't give
you a moment's
thought I just take the credit and
practice my speech I think I've been
very vocal about how much I despise
Barbie as a lifelong Barbie fan I don't
think a single one of them should have
been nominated for anything maybe the
raspberry the Razzi I thought it was a
dreadful it was so but you know the
thing is they spent more money patriarch
SP more money on the market the we
should tell you everything you need what
is the patriarchy but it wasn't for you
but the film wasn't for you yes it was
for me and I hated we celebrate
matriarchy right I celebrate the
matriarchs in my family very strong
women down every single generation we
celebrate the matriarchy why can't we
celebrate strong men anymore well I have
got the ick from Ryan Gosling I have to
say I really don't understand why you
put out that statement it do you know
what it act embarrassing no no no it was
mansplaining it was man because there
were two types of feminists the well
there are three types of feminists the
ones that I like who I identify with
which you just want equality of rule
that's great uh then there are the
vengeful feminists who want to kill all
men and then there are the worst type of
all which are the weak male virtue
signaling feminists who pop up in all
these things great goling has fall into
this trap and try and position
themselves as friend of the feminist oh
shut up all of you he's being polite
he's made a film with these two women
who are pretty successful in there I've
even got zubie laughing there they and
theyve and they've got nothing and he
has got the nomination the bloke he was
the only he was the only tolerable part
of that film and sorry this whole male
feminist rant most male feminists are
just trying to get laid to be honest let
me uh let me go back to zubie he's been
smirking away with this I think getting
more and more into the Scandal as he
hears more about it um a filmmaker
called Kenya Baris is directing new
remakes of It's a Wonderful Life in
Wizard ofar two of my favorite films to
of course give diverse reboots for
people you hadn't felt seen uh I got a
say when I read these stories my heart
sinks it's like when Disney tried to
remake Snow White in the seven dwars and
not give any dwarf actors any roles uh
because why can't we just celebrate
great movies as they were intended to be
at the time like we do great music great
sport we can accept life moves on you
can make new movies why do we have to
ruin
everything zie convince me I'm wrong
it's a very strange thing yeah it's it's
a very strange thing Piers because this
has been going on for years and it
backfires every single time the movies
tend to bomb they lose money they get
low rankings from audiences but they
keep on doing it over and over whether
this is the all female reboot of
Ghostbusters or this is uh you know race
swapping various characters and
different things people don't really
like it especially when you mess with
their childhood history in such a way if
you want to create new characters and
create new Concepts and ideas then go
out and create new characters and
Concepts and ideas don't take things
that have been loved and known for 50 or
100 years and go and gender swap them or
race swap them all it does is it really
creates more contempt and resentment and
Division in society um I think that if
you really want to have true diversity
you just let people do what they do and
you naturally end up with varying
degrees of diversity it's not something
you try you force and actually the more
you force it the more resentful you make
people and you know uh AA the original
Wizard of Oz which is a brilliant movie
featured more than 120 dwarves who
played munchkins most of them are from a
performing group in Germany landed the
roles after escaping the country just
months before the Nazis invaded Poland
this is likely to have saved their lives
as Nazi policy was for a pogram of
undesir bles and they believe that
included dwarves right it should be
noted also there were no white men in
lead roles in wi of O Dorothy a tin man
a scarecrow and a talking lion how much
more diverse do you want it to be look I
just think it's a quite a fantastic PR
move isn't it if you're bringing out a
new film to say that you are making it
woke because then it gets on programs
like yours and then Millions more people
they're doing it just to wind me up well
they're they do they do but look you got
two classic films you probably cannot
better so if you're going to make two
films in their mold you want people to
compare and contrast and look for the
differences that's why you'll do it with
diversity give some it's just it's just
laziness really they're only
capitalizing on the name so if you have
the name of Barbie the wizard of O you
don't have to put in any effort and we
talk about it which gives them all the
free publicity so if we ignored it they
probably would do better I know but if
we ignored it we wouldn't have the
chance to to slam them you want to see
them though don't you you want to see
him even if you go along to say that's
awful absolutely not I want to see the
first supposedly diverse posters for the
new thing watch the public go what are
you doing then watch them perform a
U-turn and went to barie my daughter is
she watched it I had to give her a
reprogramming session you're a secret
Barbie boy
reprogram my family zuie great to talk
to you thank you so much for joining us
come back soon Pat thank you very much
indeed over here on S the next Donald
Trump is back triumphant in Iowa and now
New Hampshire is the former president
riding a wave that will take him
sensationally all the way back to the
White House well Benny Johnson and Lara
Trump Donald's daughter-in-law are up
[Music]
next
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online we on
your smart speaker as well you know what
I love about to today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beeps and the clanks
and when it goes roll unexpected item in
bagging area I know are we only going to
be trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from Graham was president of the
Cambridge Union which is the rubbish
version of being president of the Oxford
unit Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking living if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan should
have a great big orange sticker over
here saying watch out vegans about
Twitter you sons of can you please
reinstate my account thank you this is a
major Summit President Biden decided
this was important after watching a Tom
Cruz film
kids think all they have to do is take
pictures of everything just shut down
Tik Tok problem solved when I say I am
God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a
rational talk TV is the only place where
you get the
truth
[Music]
this is talk
TV welcome back to on sensor Donald
Trump last night became the first
Republican presidential candidate to win
open races in both Iowa and New
Hampshire a feat only accomplished
before by setting president you got 55%
of the vote in New Hampshire making a
presidential rematch between Trump and
Biden looking now all but certain Nikki
Haley Trump's only remaining rival for
the GOP nomination pledged to fight on
though telling her supporters there are
dozens of States left to go and there
are but there will be increasing
pressure Trump keeps winning for her to
pull out too President Biden meanwhile
on the New Hampshire Democrat primary is
a writing candidate little known
Challenger Dean Phillips managed very
creditable 20% a measure perhaps of the
president's deep unpopularity approval
ratings are currently at 33% and no
incumbent president has ever been
reelected with approval numbers that low
well I'm joining now by Lara Trump as in
advisor of Donald Trump's presidential
campaign and his daughter-in-law it must
be said and by the political commentator
Benny Johnson well welcome to both of
you um Lara great to have you on
uncensor thank you you you're a great
singer I happen to know this from my oh
my knowledge of your family um and you
once recorded a cover of Tom Petty's
song I Won't Back Down and I can't think
of a more appropriate song to describe
your father-in-law who looked dead and
buried politically a 18 months ago and
is now right back where he wants to be
uh in fact winning in a way he didn't do
when he first got elected president in
2016 with Iowa and New Hampshire how has
he done this yeah he's amazing I mean
Piers you know he this is this is a guy
who really won't back down and I think
any other human being on this planet
quite frankly with all that he has had
against him would have said enough I
mean I think we we can all pretty
clearly see the goal of so much of what
they've done to Donald Trump and whether
they being the Department of Justice
obviously that has been weaponized
against him in so many respects the
mainstream media here in this country
his opponents in the swamp in Washington
DC man they've leveled everything at him
and he's not backing down he's not
giving up any normal person would but I
really do believe he understands what's
at stake right now in this country and
really for the rest of the world um it
is our job to be the leader of the Free
World I think in in the United States
and we've always taken that very
seriously right now we are in a weaken
State we have a weak President we have
an economy that's not doing well people
across this country are suffering they
want Donald Trump back I think he knows
he's the only shot and you know what
he's in it to win it and and yeah we've
had a couple of great primaries uh in
caucus is 2 and0 now we're gonna go on
and uh head to November 5th you know my
phone went on Monday night I was just
about to come in to do the show and it
was Donald and we hadn't spoken since
our rather contentious interview we did
actually launching this show
a while ago but a very nice chat and I
got to say he was exuding chilling
confidence about what is happening he
really just believes he's G to
win yeah I and I think he believes
because the American people believe I
mean you look at the way he's made
history and the first two tests really
of him as a candidate for president
again and it's it's not even fair to
call him that I mean so many people kind
of consider him an incumbent in so many
ways but he proved himself here in 2016
when the people of this country said we
want to give an outsider a businessman a
shot how will he do it was amazing he
did things in four years in this country
that most presidents wouldn't dream of
doing in two full terms in office um and
so I think he is feeling confident you
saw he had a blowout win in Iowa and
then to go to New Hampshire a state that
if Nikki Haley had any shot at winning
any state across this country in a
primary race against Donald Trump she
would want to be in New Hampshire
because that's where they have of course
an Open Primary people who are not
affiliated with the Republican Party
didn't come vote and you look at the win
he had last night it was really amazing
listen I remember him saying to me once
I remember him saying to me once that he
said you got to you got to win he say
Muhammad Ali said you know if you're
going to uh talk the talk you got to
walk the walk or the ACT doesn't play uh
Benny let me bring you in you'd be
waiting patiently here um one of the
great advantages that Donald Trump has
is that in 2020 Joe Biden was was able
to run as the anti-trump after a very
difficult year for the country with the
pandemic which wrecked all Trump's
economic plans as it did everywhere
around the world um this time Biden has
to run on his own record and his
approval rating says it all on almost
every key policy initiative from
immigration to the economy to Crime you
name it he's in the tank with the
American people um that has got to help
Donald Trump hasn't it in a general
election yeah like not good not a great
strategy actually what Democrats have
done first off could you imagine being a
Joe Biden voter right now like C can you
name a single accomplishment that you'd
be particularly proud of there's nothing
less cool than being a Joe Biden voter
especially as a young person and that is
why you're seeing young people abandoned
Joe Biden I'm looking at NBC News
polling right now in front of me the
number one problem with Joe Biden's
Coalition young people are abandoning
Joe Biden Donald Trump is winning with
voters ages 18 to 34 46% to 42% when was
the last time you saw that for a
Democrat but it gets even worse Donald
Trump is leading with Hispanics and Joe
Biden has collapsed in his support with
black Americans down to 63% a collapse
of 25 points since taking office also
they have turned Donald Trump into a
gangster that also a big mistake you've
made an icon out of your political rival
you've given him a mug shot as you can
see here behind me in the studio this is
totally hardcore ratchet stuff that kids
actually love that's become a meme
online and you've turned the man who was
already an American icon into a bigger
icon everybody likes voting for the
political prisoner and you uh done effed
up Democrat and you know what Donald
Trump is the only person I know where if
he was actually convicted of any one of
the things he's been charged with and
actually put into to a prison cell he's
the only person I know that could
probably still win the presidential
election because the more they try and
throw this stuff at him the more popular
he gets Piers Chris Rock uh had a comedy
set that he did in Washington DC with
nany py in the audience and Chris Rock
said you're gonna turn Donald Trump into
Tupac he's gonna sell more records yeah
you're stupid and well Nancy p got you
Smith and slapped him in the face it's
actually very interesting you mentioned
uh Chris Rob because I was at the New
York Knicks in Manhattan the day after
the 2016 election and I found myself at
a table sitting next to Chris Rock and
we got talking I said to him why do you
think Hillary Clinton lost you went let
me tell you why I said because if
someone's murdered eight people don't go
around telling everyone he's murdered
nine and the point he was making was if
you wildly exaggerate everything with
Trump and let's be honest I mean even
Lara would admit he's probably not the
most Angelic human being ever put on to
God's Earth I would never admit such a
thing here please but I don't think even
he would admit that you think that as a
Badge Of Dishonor but the you know the
reality is that this constant attempt to
take him down uh culminating in the
hypocrisy in my view of the liberal side
led by senior Democrats up and down the
country saying we've got to get rid of
trump and stop him running again to save
democracy and then they try and remove
him from presidential State ballots
which of course is the most blatant
example of trying to thwart democracy
and allowing Americans to have a free
vote imaginable so there's a kind of
nonsensical hypocrisy but also as you
mentioned Benny a stupidity which is
make him hardcore if you try and K kill
him off this way and all it does is make
him more popular stop doing it you know
the Defence of insanity is doing the
same thing over again and expecting a
different result people identify with
him Piers people who feel like the
system here has screwed them for their
entire life they look at that mug shot
of Donald Trump by the way the Democrats
thought that was it that was going to be
the nail in the coffin for him that mug
shot that mug shot represents to so many
people all across this country hey the
same system that hasn't been working for
me is working against him and I
understand it and I see myself in that
they done messed up with that one let me
how much has he made from that mug shot
I heard he was merchandising it and
making an absolute forun it's all for
the campaign we should actually keep a
tab I had Christmas wrapping paper with
the mug shot on it you've turned him
into a rebel right you've made him the
Sex Pistols you've turned him into the
Ramones he's now a rebel and kids like
voting for The Rebel but again again
Benny I would I would again bring this
back to to Joe Biden the great Advantage
Trump has is the condition of the the
sitting president this is a clip of
Biden yesterday trying to pronounce the
name of the country he
represents we'll teach Donald Trump an
valuable lesson don't mess with him Amer
unless you want to get the
benefit I think he was trying to say
United States of America but he just he
couldn't get it out and we see endless
clips of him falling over on stage
falling off bicycles tripping down the
the steps of Air Force One and so on
he's up against Trump a a a very old 81
year old not because he's 81 because
Mick Jaggers a few months younger and is
as fit as a fiddle is just he looks like
he's 181 and if you Trump you must be
licking your lips that this guy's going
to be your
opponent it would be bad not if it was
if it was just that by the way but it's
also that coupled with the fact that
everything's a disaster around Joe Biden
right I'm sorry to cut you off Benny but
that's the truth is you can lie to
people and you can try and do the jazz
hands that the Democrats do with the
media all the time only so long but
whenever it hits people's bottom line
when they know that their life is harder
right now in addition to seeing stuff
like that I mean you're exactly right
Joe Biden is basically serving up the
entire thing to us right now I hope that
uh that there's no uh funny business
with 3: a dumps this time around that's
all Benny I mean in the end Trump he's
got some State got to choose a vice
president pick who if you were him who's
the smart play for
Trump the smart play is absolutely
somebody who's young enough and
energetic enough to carry forward the
Maga movement Donald Trump will get
constitutionally one term in office so
you have to pick someone who's not going
to backstab you like a Mike Pence and
somebody who's not going to betray you
like a Nikki Haley and so you should
choose somebody like either Tucker
Carlson or V Ron Swami who are True
Believers but are younger and who have
this long stretch of a political career
ahead of him so that you have a torch to
pass when you are done with term two
okay Lara what your thoughts on VP pick
you probably know well I I well I would
and I would never break any news here
tonight T of course that's want you to
break news if I did know uh I listen I
agree with with Benny I think that
you've seen a lot of of the youth coming
into this party in a way that really I
think was very unexpected for people
look at VI and I mean the energy this
guy brings I was on stage with him last
night with my father-in-law he's
incredible but whoever it is I can
guarantee you this they will be an
America First Patriot they will be
somebody who as Benny said will carry
the mantle of this movement because he
changed my father-in-law changed the
entire face of politics in this country
he changed the Republican party it will
have to be someone who is in line with
him on that front um and it's it's
exciting stuff we're breaking history
we're making history over here you
mentioned change there so I want to just
ask you maybe a more difficult question
I've seen glimpses of your father-in-law
when he made his victory speech in Iowa
not so much after New Hampshire but an
IA of the kind of charm um civility
decency uh that I saw a lot of when I
did the Celebrity Apprentice over the
boardroom table for week in week out um
which he's been reluctant to show
actually when he's been a
politician is he a is HE capable at his
age now of actually pivoting to a
slightly more dare I say if he was to be
reelected a less bombastic slightly more
inclusive
president well it is Donald Trump uh so
to make a prediction like that uh would
be you know he he'll do what he thinks
is best and the interesting thing with
him is yeah you probably saw two very
different Donald Trump's in the Iowa uh
victory speech and in last night's New
Hampshire victory speech but he chooses
his tone based on the moment and I think
his tone was very appropriate in Iowa
and quite frankly last night I feel like
it was very appropriate as well right
now we have an election to win we do not
need to be fighting within the
Republican party for the obvious
Republican nominee to actually take that
title we should galvanize our support
together we should go forward we should
make sure that we leave nothing to
chance on November 5th because we have
to take back the White House appears we
have no other option in this country and
quite frankly I don't think the rest of
the world has another option but to have
Donald Trump back in the white house I
think the rest of the world is in a
mixture of shock and awe and horror and
delight and curiosity at the impending
return of Donald Trump the Teflon Dawn
we will'll see it's going to be a
fascinating year Lara great to see you
thank you so much send the family Qui
Benny final words may I ask you a
question may I ask you a question yeah
this is a question that The Internet's
been asking for a very long time and we
don't have an answer and it must come
from you
sir were you in a movie with Donald
Trump called Home Alone 2 that is not
you kit lady that is not me Home Alone 2
I'm grateful for the chance to put the
records straight helped Kevin that's
actually a female actress it's not me it
looks nothing like there's no shame in
it
Pi no sh not the pigeon lady in Home
Alone too although I do go in Central
Park a lot and I can see the resemblance
but it's not me but thank you Benny I
appreciate it you got your viral moment
you
ble good to have you on the program too
finally uh Lara thank you very much uh
and we'll see what happens going to be a
fascinating fascinating year for
American politics great to see you thank
you and S next Brandon kavar a
well-known pianist with over 2 million
subscribers on YouTube but that's not
why he's gone viral this week Chinese
Communists might be responsible Brendon
we'll explain
[Music]
next we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online and we're on your smart
speaking criminals to using XL Bully
dogs as weapons to to threaten others no
matter how well Tred I don't sort of
bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the
other sakir starma is about to help make
children even taller
now he go that's what's going to happen
if you vote
labor Long Live JK Rowling and her right
to stand up for women we can only pity
those who despise her straightforward
Politics as somehow
dangerous the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million pound so far so40 million so far
results nil absolutely nil Kevin O
Sullivan is the worst presenter on talk
TV sitting on his
fat was like brought to you by Ste child
the mayor of London ought us with our
own money the the mayor's fireworks very
rarely meet anybody that says you know
the thing about London is it's got a
great mayor a deep K brilliant
Guy this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cru fil stop creating all
of these funny little factions with
their funny little names the new
conservatives the ERG the common sense
research group the red wool red trouser
popcorn I mean popcorn what what is that
I just cannot see if Rishi suak goes
does what David Frost what Lord Frost
wants him to do and go further to the
right on taxes and immigration that that
would turn around the what's predicted
by this poll in a landslide Donald Trump
didn't just win he obliterated this is a
guy facing nearly a 100 criminal charges
and yet all that's done is actually make
him more popular Trump is canny enough
to know that all publicity is good
publicity I don't want a president who's
been impeached if he's able to bamboozle
you or that's the way it goes I did my 6
months I came back nobody would touch me
I put my head down and persisted and
carry on when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it actually not
my job to answer your questions I've
asked you two questions should a mass
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV is
the only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
that welcome back to unsensitive pianist
Brendan kavar AKA Dr K was entertaining
crowds at some pan Station in London on
the public piano there when he's
approached by a group of flag waving
Chinese onlookers who demanded he
stopped filming in a shocking twist the
police seem to back the tourists and
today the piano's been mysteriously
cordoned off all very mysterious um it
was quite bizarre Dr K you join me now I
watched the whole video to get a proper
context for this you're just minding
your own business sure you're playing
Beautiful piano as you do you're a very
talented guy thank you p uh people are
enjoying it and they your stick is they
come over and interact with you and it's
great and very harmless and fun um and
this is a un action I mean fantastic but
then this group Chinese people in the
background with their with their Flags
yes come over and sort of believe they
have the right to stop you filming and
doing what you're doing let's have
listen to what happened okay this is all
right to we protecting and that's it but
what right I don't understand image
right we are protecting our own image
right you're not sharing but this we're
in public yeah exactly but we're in a
free country mate true communist China
now you know oh I'm sorry this is reist
now we have no we're not in communist
China we're in a country got a Chinese
flag there it doesn't matter show me the
Chinese flag why you're touching her
stop touching her don't touch her please
do not touch her please you are not the
same age please do not touch her don't
touch her it was totally bizarre he got
very angry that guy but I also thought
The policewoman Who Would came over to
you I didn't like what she was doing
either which is almost acquiescing to
this well absolutely she completely took
the side of the Chinese because they
mentioned the r word
um racist uh she melted like a jelly and
and nothing you said was racist at all
well I I think she said her her beef
with me was that I said we I said we're
not in China now yeah and she found that
an extremely offensive phrase because
she said that would hurt the feelings of
the Chinese around the piano and you can
hear her Whispering you can't say that
and I said what and she said you can't
say we're not in China now I said that's
a factual statement and I think when the
police deal with these politically
correct issues they're all over the
place because they think they're going
to offend someone and so she took it out
on me she thought she was I suppose
virtue signaling signaling to her
Masters and uh but she didn't the iry is
they were filming themselves some kind
of commercial and they were also filming
me it's been pointed out if you actually
watch the video there's a guy in a
gimbal from from the CCP uh uh group
that was there who was constantly
filming me one of the girls was filming
me but they said I wasn't allowed to
film them and that I needed to delete my
footage because they had uh a disclaimer
that no one was allowed to film them in
the station quite bizar what's it's
really hit a nerve over six million
people and now watch this online you
probably never had a reaction quite like
this well no and also I've got to tell
you I've just before I came in Piers
I've just had a phone call the video is
on the verge of being taken down by
YouTube because I've had a second strike
against it so someone does not want this
video to be taken uh doesn't want this
video to be there um it's about to be
taken down so if anyone's watching this
please download it and if the video
disappears um obviously pressure has
been put on YouTube to what does it tell
you about where we are with free speech
in the world right uh well this whole
thing was a mini parable about the value
of free speech it was a spontaneous live
stream um we were attempted to be shut
down um but in the end Free Speech
prevailed and I think that's why it's
got such a lot of traction around the
world because where do you see free
speech prevailing in in a little mini
drama um and that's what happened they
walked away free speech prevailed but
now they want to take the video down the
video is on the verge of being taken
down please if you're watching this
download the video and if the video gets
taken down let's kick up a stink how did
the police end up with you over the
whole thing they called the there was
about five of them and one of the one of
the group went and got the police and
said that we've got here a violent Thug
who is threatening us and is's calling
us Communists and uh we feel threatened
and he also needs to delete his footage
and uh the police lady immediately took
their side and uh she gave me quite a
hard time she told me I couldn't say
things she said to stop filming no I
watched it I was I couldn't understand
what she was doing well I knew what she
was doing understand it either P you
know reaction of youan have you been
back since to play the piano uh no my my
friend Terry I've got a good friend my
friend Terry miles God bless him he was
there today he's a he's a fantastic uh
YouTuber he was there today and there
was even a protest today supporting the
piano and Me in St panras free the piano
Terry was there today the piano's back
and I think the P when are you back
there I don't know if I should say p yes
you should do you think I should go back
ad absolutely give me your would you
come with me back tomorrow morning you
reckon yes you reckon of course you'll
be a superstar now you reckon you bigger
crowds than Elton John who I think I
think donated the piano he he did and
elton's team is being contacted by The
Daily Express to give a comment on the
fact that the piano was shut off um but
when they heard that they actually
released the piano so it's back in use
again but um when are you going back
come on give me a scoop PE peers peers I
I don't know if I can I Free Speech spit
it out
ma'am I might go on Friday Friday this
Friday what kind of time of people are
in town PE PE I want call motion PE peer
you're you're you're stirring this up
man you're you're stirring this up
anyone from the Communist Party in China
watching this look I can't tell you when
he's performing but it's Friday look MI5
have told me to keep a low I'm J I'm
only joking but look I I'm I may be
there on Friday but I you know it's it's
a it's a sensitive situation um the
police British transport police have
freaked out St panras have freaked out
but people have you know what they
should all just calm down and recognize
we live last time I checked in a free
Democratic country and you are allowed
to play the piano where you've played it
many times we got to leave it there
great to see you Brendon all the best
get down us and panas we're all behind
you that's it from me whatever you're up
to keep it un sensing especially from
the Communists in China God bless you
[Music]
P we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
they have made a statement condemning
Hamas we expect to see the crown revisit
Harry's anti-semitic Halloween costume
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about to today we do it all sunak sella
scun I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
he delivered the referendum that he said
he would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the tor's love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and rishy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sunak has done the
question now is what he next the police
are pro Palestine that is just not right
you swear an o in the police to act
without fear or favor the co inquiry
seems to have turned into a sort of
pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk CB
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for sadique Khan we're not stopping
until you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda silt the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £40
million so far so £140 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking
if you're walking towards me and you're
a vegan should have a great big orange
sticker over here saying watch out
vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man MC mous
man he should be easy enough to catch
this guy shouldn't he I mean he's got
house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film